so I just read the room here a little
bit find out why everybody's coming to
see my talk
um how many people actually use Vizio
all right that's popular how many people
have actually programmed with Vizio
actually written the software that had
Vizio involved
who knows about the shape sheet physio
shape sheet
oh boy okay how about how about
programming with uh using other more
modern internet tools like draw i o or
or
JavaScript based Frameworks that do
drawing
work with HTML5 canvas anybody no
about working with games game engines
like Unity or
okay Unity or unreal
okay cool well then there's going to be
some new stuff here for you I think
you'll think you'll enjoy it
so
um
that's why I think you're here and I
think you're interested in a Vizio
inspired native programmable drawing
tool I mean wouldn't that be cool and
you wonder if maybe you could do it with
blazer do we have any Blazer developers
here or people just
okay well you're in for a treat
uh there's uh I wanted to learn Blazer
and this is the project I did to help me
and in the end I think we're going to
have an open source library that has all
these capabilities so I'm playing hope
and Source this for the community
okay
so this is what we'll cover what what
comprises reinvented Vizio
how did that get inspired and yes Blazer
can do it and there's going to be some
cool examples here and I'm going to give
you uh some tricks and tips that I've
learned when I was implementing it
because in all honesty I learned
Vizio just
this year I mean not Vizio Blazer just
this year okay
so what is reinvented Visio solution
well it's all the things that Vizio can
do mostly all the things that Vizio can
do plus the advantages of modern web
apps
okay
oh and by the way what you're seeing in
my presentation this is a blazer there's
a presentation written in blazer because
I figured I'm learning it I might as
well really learn it so anyhow so I want
to show you some Vizio solutions that I
have built in the past this is nearly uh
20 years ago that I built these things
but they're all focused on having a
subject matter expert actually draw a
diagram and then I would reason over the
diagram that they drew and I would then
generate a program that could do the
product configuration or whatever tasks
they had at hand this way I was able to
let them specify the rules and I and as
a programmer I tried to put myself out
of work
and let them specify the rules and
actually as a result many of these
applications have had a lifespan of
20 years or so because they're able to
create their own rules so one of the
first pro one of the products we built
was a knowledge capture system for
product configuration this was used by a
large multinational Hospital chain and
our company makes hospital equipment
what they liked about Vizio is that
Vizio could do
measured drawings so they could lay in a
floor plan drop Wi-Fi shapes that
represented Wi-Fi and as they dropped
those shapes those shapes would
configure the equipment that they needed
they would calculate the labor to
install that shape they would calculate
the lengths of the wires they would put
equipment in the in the bill of
materials and you then produce a bill of
materials so that's the kind of thing I
want in a web-based web-based version of
Vizio
another project we had was a customer
who was producing tires
and they need to to plan all the molds
that had to be designed for all the
different sizes of tires so what they
did is they laid out a project plan and
in the project plan they put rules about
what sub projects should be created how
things should be sized what additional
components needed to be there and when
they ran that project plan for any one
of the product lines that they built it
would generate Microsoft Project
solution for every one of the steps
so
one of my favorites here was the 3D
wiring application
actually had people draw schematics in
2D then they would put equipment in
racks from the front view
then they put equipment in racks from
the top view
and they they lay cable Trace over top
of it and so the what the program then
did was reason over all of the
schematics figure out what the real
wires were and Route them
automatically and it did it perfectly
every time
except one time
guy comes in from the back room and he
says all these wires are too short
and
the engineer guy looked at it and said
no these wires are supposed to go
through the floor not through the
ceiling you've got your drawing upside
down
it all worked so what's nice about that
though is we introduced the 3D
capability because I'm going to tell you
it's so much easier to see if it's right
than calculate if it's right so building
the 3D part was actually worth it
so another odd application we got
involved in was a legal decision
management I don't know if I'm not a
lawyer but but uh
uh the laws broken up into many smaller
arguments that have to be assembled kind
of with hand butts and oars to actually
prove to win your case and so here we
actually built a solution uh with a law
professor who's a Yale trained graduate
and uh
well thought of in the industry he
helped us design this solution where
um
where he would document
how the law was supposed to be reasoned
over and then put cases in to do that
so you might ask
how does a mechanical engineer
meet such as brilliant lawyer that can
help with the project
my married his sister
so that helped
anyhow and then here as a mechanical
engineer this is one of my favorites
here is we actually did an integration
to SolidWorks does anyone know
SolidWorks a cad CAD solution right so
they can actually we actually ask the
SolidWorks parts to extract the
parameters that were associated they
would come into Vizio we would then draw
diagrams that said this parameter is
these is this value under these
circumstances you then execute the model
and you'd watch SolidWorks jump through
hoops assembling and sizing all the
parts so that was a lot of fun so to me
these are what these are what you can do
with Vizio these are visio-like
applications it's never just a drawing
tool for me my customers love these
tools
but when it was they wanted to go the
internet and Vizio just wasn't ready to
go there so
so that's that's what's inspired me
over the last couple years to go back
and reinvent Vizio using web
Technologies and maybe you guys have
used some of the web Technologies to see
here and so every Christmas or so I say
let's try it again what's new and I
learn a new technology and uh basically
call the library Foundry and and just
keep working at it until I get something
that looks like like those Vizio
applications
so my current the current iteration is
here with I call a Foundry Blazer and
it's with um HTML5 canvas and 3js for 3D
graphics
okay so here's the approach that I take
to learning you as developers probably
have something similar but when I pick a
new tile technology I go back to a
domain that I understand so I'm only
learning one thing at a time
and then I just get started there's
there's just genius in beginning just
try it and find a find example to do it
so
I call that implementation focused
learning
where you look at Learning in either a
new new learning a new technology or
learning a do a new domain those are all
things that we have to do as developers
all the time I find myself always
learning new technologies and I find
myself getting excited about what it is
I can Implement in that new technology
and I challenge myself in very small
three-hour increments can I get it to do
this can I get it to do this right right
and I just walked worked the way so what
you're seeing today is something I
started in Christmas at Christmas
in uh in uh stolen hours on the weekends
and at nights okay
so uh and uh if I was having such
Success With It
I thought I'd apply to NDC and now I'm
here
so so there you go
so the current current Visio reinvention
challenge here
is can we get it to be programmable can
we create custom shapes can we use glue
to represent objects and how they're
connected and can I make it happen as a
drawing service that surface that
perhaps you could use in your own
applications just by bringing in a nuget
package but now I want to add all this
good stuff that's everybody expects in
the web right animations needs to be web
native we want this the model and the
shape to be separate
so the data doesn't get mixed I want
multi-user collaboration and I'll show
you how it works with signalr of course
a 3D environment
okay
so
the Blazer Advantage why can blazer do
this well
um what's cool it's you first of all
it's all.net and we all know working
with the latest part of dot dot net mads
keeps advancing the language we keep
loving what he does with it uh he's um
so.net has this object-oriented side and
it has this functional side and they
both work well together and you'll see
that in the model in the.net ecosystem
you'd be surprised what open source
libraries there are probably not you
guys see them all the time and then then
the cross platform I can make it run
here I can make it run the Linux I can
make it run in a container I can make it
run in the cloud but then Blazer Builds
on top of that with the with its
extension so I can now use C sharp
everywhere up on the server up on the
client okay so and Blazer does a very
good job doing at the interops over top
of JavaScript and HTML and webgl now
we're not going to dive into those in
any of the talks but there are a lot of
talks previously at NDC and uh probably
a build this week on how those interops
work great set of third-party controls
and if you've met the people on the
Blazer team if you've watched any of
their presentations you can see that
they're thinking about the future and
it's going to be a platform that that
grows
so with that let's just do some demos
here
so again remember this is a Blazer app
this is the environment that I've built
so far this background is uh is a page
that it's actually drawn on and I want
to point out here in the upper right
hand corner this is an HTML5 canvas
element and this is the frame rate that
it's getting uh when it's doing now I
was developing this it was only getting
30 frames a second so is the electricity
faster over here or something but but
it's it's doing well I want to point
that out because I want you to pay
attention to what's going on with the
frame rate the um
uh I always have this up to tell me what
the performance is so as I make
modifications to the program I could see
did I do something to affect performance
and the other thing I added to the
solution was was
if I'm doing something on the canvas
that's affecting a calculation to be
made before it renders the next time
it marks that
area up there is red
so as we do demos you can look yourself
and and see that okay
so let's just see so this is this is a
pan Zoom window it's very common in in
uh getting things started in Vizio
over here is a 3D environment that we'll
talk about before
or later we're not going to talk about
before so uh so with that 3D and
um the panzoom environment here
I can do some very simple things like
just add my favorite blue shape it
probably wasn't a good idea to make that
blue and have the demo have a blue shape
but so I can create as many uh blue
shapes as I want
and you know as I click on one it
changes to the other I can select them
in a group and move them around I can
certainly create
an arrow shape that's very popular in
Vizio you know I asked chat GPT to
create an arrow it made this for me
okay so I think if you make arrows for a
living chat GPT is not going to take
your job
so
so we'll see some other things though in
the in the aspect so the arrows were
important because I needed to I needed
to to say well how's glue going to work
so here I've built an environment where
glue holds together
okay and then once you build 1D glue you
just gotta build 2D glue so there's that
UPC connected to the bottom it's it's
glued I cannot move that
if you're going to glue something you
might as well
push the timer through to it and so now
I've got animation
or a lot of different ways to do
animation we'll talk about that
and we'll get into some of these other
things so this is just the general
environment
it looks pretty simple a lot of things
are going on there I do want to show you
one of my favorite things
why I was doing it I was I'm an old guy
so I was inspired by the David Bowie
song Let's Dance and I just
built this crazy animation that just
move shapes around at random random area
so all these elements are here I was
able to try with all these things and
now I'm going to show you I'm going to
show you under the covers about how all
this stuff works and
you'll then have a a very good
understanding of Vizio and how all the
components fit together
uh I'm taking you from the ground up
this is what I call the part when I was
writing this presentation this is the
part
I call the Montage okay so just imagine
learning everything you need to learn
from the end of the movie to be good
okay so okay so here's uh I the the
project was inspired by Vizio
and because I had used it a lot I used
busy a lot but more importantly
I didn't want to have to learn a whole
new set of nomenclature so I just took
the names that Vizio used and used them
when I built my own application and I'm
hoping that when you guys build
applications that will work for you
whatever you learn from Vizio you can go
ahead and use it so the chord of Vizio
is the shape sheet and the chord of the
shape sheet is this is this page here
which is the transform Matrix so this is
the Matrix and that's about it's not the
Matrix but this is the part that most
people get nervous about and I'm gonna
ease your ease your pain there but you
can see that the that the transform
Matrix actually calculates
the width and height of the shape the
angle that it's at where it's placed on
the page that's the pin X and pin Y and
then the loc pin X and the log pin y are
where the center of rotation is
in my implementation I don't worry about
flip X and flip y
um they have a tendency to be
Reflections and and
not so important in the types of
applications that I built but here what
was nice about that is as preparing for
the talk I was able to just Google a
slide from Vizio to say what does that
mean and pop it in here so this is what
that means
so that's how they all work together
but here is is a DOT net code where I
have uh where I create a new 2D Matrix
and then I fill that Matrix with the pin
X the pin y the rotation I had to
calculate to radians from degrees
and then a mathematical formula which
says where the reference point is so
that's one method just to get the Matrix
off of the shape and then when
everything's rendering and you hand it
to the canvas 2D context to draw
something I have to push the Matrix into
the context and that tells that tells
the canvas go over here and start
drawing
go over there and start drawing right so
that's how that's how you get a lot of
things uh to draw wherever you want on
the canvas or one technique
now what Vizio also did
was they designed a
geometry section where you can put in
any kind of geometry you want this
happens to be geometry for a arrow
and you can see here that the geometry
is set up by having a bunch of move and
draw commands like turtle or or these
other kinds of languages move to line
two and you can see that it's all
parametric based on the height and the
width right so so all the drawings that
are in in Vizio mostly happen inside the
shape and that's how that makes they
make that happen
okay so what that then allows me to do
here's some actual.net code that I wrote
I wrote function methods to actually
draw stuff to represent the geometry so
you can see you can see how simple draw
boxes you just draw a filled rectangle
from zero zero in the upper left hand
corner to the height width and depth to
the height and width and then draw box
uh is is without fill and then I have a
great draw Circle here
then I got tired of doing that because
that gets complicated so I asked chat
GPT to draw a square and this is what it
came with up no sorry I asked it to draw
a star because the star could be
complicated
and this is what it came up with for me
with code and that one worked so bad
Arrow good it starts but
um you can see here though it uses the X
and Y look uh data exactly like this up
here
right so I don't know maybe it read
Vizio in the background so let's talk a
little about drawing and rendering and
the difference so here I have three
separate shapes here
and I ask each shape to render its
details and in the process of rendering
its details it has an option to call a
function
any one of these functions here to draw
whatever it needs to draw and you can
override these functions dynamically
because they're functions you just push
it into the shape
so uh and then you can stack them up so
you can see here that this is drawing
the shape draw and then it draws the
hover draw over top of it which is just
the red line and then I get this
selection draw okay you also notice
there's another method I can call here
called context link and I can do that
just before the transform
so so what that allows you to do then is
tell this shape to glue itself to
another shape because you can write a
function that moves that shape to you or
pushes it away at any time and that's
something that um that just showed up
from using Blazer so I went on to go and
build the rest of the stuff associated
with uh
Visio drawing so this is a very common
nomenclature Vizio drawing is made up of
many pages
the pages
have many shapes on them and the shapes
can have sub shapes on them as well and
and the shapes are classified as being
2D or 3D or whatever they they need to
be to be that action now in the days or
early days of Vizio they didn't have
real objects that represented the shapes
they just had another section of the
shape sheet and so you would get this
kind of object-oriented programming by
checking to see if that feature was
there or not right so uh what we can do
now in the modern age is we can inherit
and make classes and I think I've struck
a good balance between some things that
are functions and some things in our
classes but what I like about this now
is that you can not only have the The
Base Class of 2D and a base class of 3D
but now you can have have uh parallel
shapes I have a 3D shape when I go to 3D
I have a 3D text when I go to text I
have a page in 2D on 3D I have a stage
so so it's very parallel in the models
now this is how Vizio defined a 1D shape
and what's different about a 1D shape
than a 2d shape is it's given these two
extra parameters here of the beginning
and the end
and that's where you would attach and
glue that's how it calculates something
but you notice that it has formulas now
for the pin X and pin Y which is the
center of where those two points are it
also has has the width of the shape
that's calculated using Pythagorean
theorem and it's actually figures out
the angle based on the tangent so
perhaps you didn't know this but when
you were drawing with 1D shapes and
Vizio
they were really 2D shapes hiding from
you with a different drawing method so
what's nice about that is you can use
that coordinate system when you're
building something special
okay so glue glue is very tricky
and I'll just walk through the steps
here glue's kind of an invisible element
that connects the two that connects a 1D
shape to a 2d shape the 1D shape owns
that glue so for example if I move that
green shape
that's going to tell that green shape to
invalidate that its own Matrix property
so it's going to talk to the glue that's
shared between it and any other shape in
this case it's just one blue shape
it's going to talk to that glue and that
glue is going to talk to the shape that
it who owns it the the blue shape and as
a result the blue shape will will
invalidate its Matrix and on the next
rendering a draw cycle they will
recalculate where the end of that Arrow
should be
and and it looks like and that Arrow
then go jumps to that place so it
creates this this feeling of glue that
everything's connected together because
of the render cycle happening all the
time and you can move one shape and it
can affect others and and the chain is
smart enough to stop so
okay so the other part we needed to add
to the Vizio was uh Vizio had stencils
and a ways for you to extend that I've
built this application so you could
extend it yourself all of these menu
items over all these items over here are
us jumping into these different
extensions and you from those extensions
you can access any of the apis and
influence the drawing okay so the way
usually what happens when you get things
talking to each other in a Loosely
couple mode you have to set up a publish
a pub sub technique where you throw data
out whoever's listening to it will
affect that so this is uh that mechanism
is built in and Blazer actually has a
toolkit that helps you do that as well
so we're using that
and now we get to the rules of rendering
so so uh this this picture is very
detailed but I'll give you a kind of a
high level thing of what's going on
remember seeing the rendering cycle up
in the upper left hand corner 70 frames
a second or whatever that's only
happening because the canvas is sending
us a message it says I think I can do 70
frames a second oh wait I can do 30 I
can do 20 right it keeps changing and
that's that sequence of events that are
coming down from the from the top at
that point I have to hand over the power
I have to hand over my render routine to
the canvas and it draws the picture okay
so that can take different lengths of
time here
but and you'll never get an event that's
right on top of the other one so what
happens is in between the time we have
to update and change the model like if
the glue changes or anything like that
so if an event comes in and we just
change the model that's great and we get
multiple events that could change
something which can change something
else as long as all that work gets done
before the next render cycle we're great
sometimes an animation comes in and now
what we have to do is kind of quickly
change some things just before we draw
it so the animation is driven by the
drawing cycle but sometimes you'll get
events that show up while you're drawing
okay so what you got to do with those is
just cue them up and then save them for
the next drawing cycle so that's the
magic of making it so that the
application doesn't stutter when you're
starting to move these shapes around and
that was actually I started building it
and I ran into that problem and I said
and that's the solution I came up with
just small incremental make it make it
work and make it right make it perform
so here's an example of the events
coming through as I'm moving one of
these shapes and you can see not only is
it moving all the things that's
connected to it but it's also moving
itself in the little View Window as well
okay
so Blazer Blazer can can do this stuff
but here's the ultimate goal of what I
wanted to achieve I wanted two people to
be able to collaborate together and
create an own drawing and probably in 20
minutes we'll see that okay
so
uh what happens is is the the
dark figures here on the page are
represent the people they work with a
tool like moving something with a mouse
that's sent to these Foundry API
Services which then draw which then draw
on their own canvas and they package up
what they did
just their little message pass that
through the command service the command
service hits against signalr Hub it's a
duplex mechanism so data can fly through
either direction
it goes to the other
Hub or someone else who's listening it
gets decoded in that person's command
service and that command service then
draws on the screen the drawings are
kept synchronized and the effect is that
the other person's looking over your
shoulder while they're drawing
okay
so so with that I'm sorry that was a lot
but that gives you the background here
let's do some demos and let's look at
some
some scenarios
so here's a set of demos that I have
hope to get through them all I
definitely want to hit the collaboration
here at the end but there's some good
stuff on along the way
so let's let's talk about hit testing
okay so
um
the quad tree is a technique that I
learned about when I was doing this
version of my my implementation it's a
fast way to speed up the hit testing
and what's important about a hodge
quad tree is that a hit test is you
finding an object under a mouse cursor
okay and you don't want to do something
where you just look through a long list
of objects and saying are you there are
you there are you there
so it's a very common task yeah I got to
figure out how to do it quickly and a
quad tree is a data structure that
divides the page into smaller and
smaller pieces as it needs it so the
search can be fast think of binary
search in a visual way right so when I
was doing this I I couldn't imagine how
I did it so what I always do is I always
create a visual visualization that helps
me debug it and it saves me a lot of
time I don't like to pour through logs
and all this other sort of stuff
so let's just take a look at that real
quick a quad Tree in action
we'll bring out our ring shape you can
see here how quick the hit tests are
that it finds things okay you also
notice that hit testing doesn't
influence
the frame rate over here let me move
some of these around just so we can
we can get it and then I will turn on a
visualization of the Quad tree and hit
test you can see here now as I actually
move elements around
things start to divide themselves up
so that my hit tests are quick and
efficient
right so when that actually worked I was
I was surprised a bit but I also then
wrote a little routine that that tracked
the mouse
so I know exactly what the data was that
I was sending in and this way I could
learn what would happen if I created a
rectangle that didn't fully enclose the
shape it wasn't
selected right so that helped me learn
more about how how quad tree and hit
testing works
so let's look at some more of the
details so here you'll see in the code
you'll see that the quad trees the
recursive algorithm that just keeps
making more of itself when it needs to
and the subdivide makes it up into those
four quarters and then when you're
looking things up in a quad tree
when you look things up in the quad tree
uh it it finds those objects
and and puts them on the screen so so
that's basically how the quad tree works
um let's look at some other
code examples okay 3D modeling well I
know I needed 3D modeling so what I what
you do in the.net community is you go
look to see if somebody's already done
it because that's a lot of work believe
me right so I went out to look to see if
there was a 3D model available
and uh what I know what I knew is that
Blazer had an interop
and I was just hoping that someone
connected it to 3js and then I could
leverage the the uh
text mechanism here when 3js was
rendering
so the I'm not trying to build a video
game here it's about building the right
tool for the job I just want to have a
3D rendering of models for all my cad
things and I was looking for an open
source Library well I found one
found one from a man named uh Roman who
uh is living in Ukraine right now
and he was willing to help extend the
library but as you can see here power
goes off for two days at a time
but so what he did do is he did provide
the open source code for me to continue
with the project and and we've added
more capabilities to it we're going to
share it back to him so it's a great
Community
um
and it's going to help you build laser
projects so here's a car that I went out
to the internet and just got a Ford
Mustang and bring that in and I want to
show you how this works
looking at static pictures of 3D stuff
is silly right right so let's go look at
the 3D World
Okay so
I now have this gamer cab here and I can
first first just to show you I can bring
in
all sorts of Primitives that are part of
that application so these are rectangles
you could set up with your own
parametric value if you want to make 3D
bar charts
go ahead this is the tool to do it right
um also here in the arena
let me restart this
so in the arena is uh
I can also bring in glb models right now
the trick with these models is is they
got to come off of the internet they got
to be loaded in that way so you what you
have to do is is ask for the model to be
loaded and then wait to hear about it
and then go ahead and render it so once
you figure that out you're able to then
bring in literally anything you can find
on the internet
right I cannot guarantee that they're
all proportionally the right size that's
your that's your problem the other the
other thing that we learned as we did
this is is uh
well I always like to stress things out
push it as far as I can so here I came
up with a technique
that uh
uh is going to try to load 1500 jet
fighters
give that uh
T-Rex a run for his money this is
running on a machine that does not have
a GPU
okay so uh you could get much better
performance on a on a more capable
machine but uh just to go look at some
of the code here for this in this
section
and I'm really okay so look for some of
the code in this section here
uh
basically uh
we asked the models to load themselves
the file name and ask the models to load
themselves
and then uh
it builds a 3D shape which is that that
file that shape gets pre-rendered called
on it
and back in the render cycle when the
pre-rendering sets up the parameters
with the X and Y coordinates and then
you know on a separate thread when it
comes back uh here we we put it back
into the model
so we figured all that stuff out for you
that as well as as
cylinder spheres all the other types of
things that you would normally do do in
a 3D model
okay so let's move on to the next sample
oh Boyd's so Boyds is a simulation of uh
that I use for stress tests does anybody
come across Boyd's before
this technique
so it's a simulation of a flock of
Birds
okay so so the simulation of these
flocking birds shows the impact of a
large number of shapes on performance so
this is a good way to test if my
modeling environment is performant and
what else I like about this is this
where I sh separate the model of the
bird or the Boyd from the actual shape
and so that's important for all these
other kinds of implementations I want to
do later where I have the model separate
so I can test that as well and then the
boy is what happens is every animation
cycle the voids recalculate what their
positions are and how they fit in the
fit in the frames
so to kind of break that down this way I
used to do it before is put the
knowledge of the Void in the shape and
it's trapped in there and I could never
extract and reuse it I wanted a system
where I could just make a.net class that
I already had and attach it to the model
so here we were able to Loosely couple
that so here's my definition of a Boyd
and I happen to create it in 3D Random
3D location in space
and here I'm using it inside a shape now
what's different about what you're
seeing here is that all these voids
are are being rendered when the shapes
being rendered they aren't individual
shapes you can do that by by adding
creating a new class that inherits from
shapes adding a draw void method
okay overriding
the render detail method for that class
okay and then write the code
that draws the voids as it's needed and
so just a very efficient way if you need
to draw a lot of things at once you can
put it inside of one shaper in the
canvas
okay the other technique is to
is to break them free and have them all
draw individually
and under these circumstances what I do
is
because I associate the void
to the pin X pin y
of the context link of the shape
remember I showed you that before so
this is like gluing a model to the shape
and now every time the shape renders it
can find out what the void's up to
okay so let's look at that one real
quick
um
Boyd's page
okay so here's
Boyd's moving into shape
you notice here when they're just
sitting here they're still moving we
aren't getting a frame rate change
okay
if I add more I can add more voids to
that shape
but now I can actually ask the Boyds to
become individual voids and now you can
see you've got this continuous frame
rate as they all change and they're all
selectable so it's kind of up to you as
to what you want to do with how you
would Implement your shapes
there's also another
interesting aspect of this Let me
refresh the model
where I have this the stage associated
with the Boyd's
so here if we
create some voids
since I had some more different colors
you can see
that
there you go that always sometimes I
don't know if they're going to be there
okay so so I'm glad to see they're all
here
right so uh
there you go so 2D 3D voids that helps
you know that you can have a model
separate from your visualizations and
this is great if you have existing.net
code that is modeling something and you
want to connect it to the platform you
can just connect it that way
okay
so
that's Boyd's
okay uh menus and user commands well
what I did here in this part of the
application you what you want to do is
use the shape model to also represent
the menus that are going to be in the
application why write that code twice
okay and what this allowed me to do then
is is create
have the menus either render themselves
as traditional menus or on the shape on
the canvas
so
let's
so your basic menu options is really
just a dictionary of of names and
commands Okay but here I have a tool uh
an API that allows me to create that
menu in terms of menu items and buttons
and then I can either ask that menu to
to draw itself on the page or Draw
itself in the application so let's look
at that in in real life demo
so it's clear the page here
so here's the menu from clear to Let's
Dance okay this menu
just creates the copy of the other menu
and now I can
apply animations or manipulate it around
but I still have all of the features
that we all love from the previous
application moving around on the screen
okay so that's how the that's how the
menus work just jump back to the code to
see
to see the last part here
the
the menus can also be drawn up here on
the top screen all you really have to do
is Loop through the menu shape items and
create
create HTML items to represent each of
them and now you have both mechanisms
and that's particularly convenient in
the more modern version of Vizio where
if you're drawing something it was
really hard to go back over to stencil
and grab something and pull it back so
now you can actually have actions that
would draw menus close to where you need
them to be drawn and you can go ahead
and click click those features okay
so that's uh that's a menu code code
sample
one thing I do a lot is Autumn is uh lay
out trees you're always laying out trees
in a video in the thing so what we want
to do is uh create a class of uh uh I
want to create a class that wraps shapes
and orchestrates their layout and that's
the best way to do it so so trees are
these hierarchical Arrangements of
shapes that are all over the diagram
and I want to automate the process of
you drawing a tree because no one likes
to draw them if you add something to a
tree it will relay out the tree and that
mechanism you can control that as well
so what we did is uh is I built my tree
layout class gave it a parent and a list
of children trees and then you basically
load the tree with your model shapes
and then ask it to lay out
according to
uh
according to horizontal or vertical
rules
so let's look at that as a demo
clear the
application so on the composition screen
I can create
the workspace demo
and there it's moving let me get it in a
good place let me turn on again I always
turn on the visuals to tell me what's
going on so here as I close the tree up
it's smaller right open it up again it's
calculated where those
parameters should be
so the algorithm for laying out the tree
becomes simple once you once you build
that wrapper around it and a lot of the
the details really just come down to
some very simple
constructs you first you calculate what
the size of of you are as the most Leaf
node
and then you out then you work your way
up asking how big you are with your
children
and so on and so on up the tree
depending upon what your style of layout
is
so once you calculate where everyone
should be then you decide how to move
them on in the space that's available
and then
finally you Loop through all of the
trees all of the tree elements and you
connect them up with the wires or cables
whichever way you want to do it
and so very simple quick algorithm you
can generate trees of of anything in
here vertical trees horizontal trees
whatever you'd prefer
okay so now we get a chance to see uh
2D shape glue in action so
so 1D glue requires a non
um
uh an object to be glued to a 2d object
okay so the glue the non-renderable part
is the glue and it sits between the two
objects so when a Target is moved the
other Target
the other Target moves or the the thing
attached to it moves to stay connected
and keep that constraint in place
so we talked about the glue before and
how that works
so um
this is what it takes from an API API
wise to glue two things together
you create the green shape and the
orange shape and put them on move them
to a certain location
I create the the
1D shape I make it an arrow I'm giving
it a special routine to draw that error
arrow and then I'm asking that Arrow to
glue the start to shape one on the right
side and glue the start to shape two on
the left side
okay so uh once you have that mechanism
in place that works no matter how much
glue is on the main shape and remember
you moving something forces everything
else to recalculate and that has to
happen between the render render
sequence
so the last part is just what does it
take to do a shape once you ask a 1D
glue shape how to do something you
create that invisible piece of glue you
mark it and you glue it together and
then you tell through this command that
it needs to recalculate itself
traditionally that's called smash or
recalculate but um
that's what we implemented in the system
so again if I go back and look at the
the demo for this
clear off the screen
okay so uh I can get my
uh 1D glue shape and move it around or
this other shape that I call
um
the tug of war here on the stencil
right
so this this shape here was was
um I have two shapes glued together and
connected as you see when it came into
the screen I had it animated to actually
help me test the glue that's my
automation technique I drop it I drop a
shape animation triggers the two shapes
pull apart the one state the one follows
it in the middle
so that's how how glue works and that
and you saw the mechanisms on how 2D
glue works as well
so let's look at the other coating
samples so with that that kind of takes
me to actually my favorite piece of code
in the whole system if you guys uh have
been working with the new versions of
dot dot net and uh c-sharp you know
about the pattern matching mechanism
here because I'm sending events across
the system I can then write a
I can then write a
pattern matching sequence
let me get it on the screen here
there you go so I have a switch
statement here that switches based on
the the type of event the type of key
was pressed and whether the alternate
key or shift keys are down at the same
time as you can see just matching those
patterns it calls the right function
inside the system and I can grow this
and you can grow it too just by adding
more patterns onto the match you build
your own key keyboard keyboard mappings
so okay
so with that we're ready to talk about
collaboration
and and to really understand
uh you want you probably want to know a
little bit about signal R and how that
mechanism works
so
uh
what do we get what we did is we built a
command service to broker the signal arm
messages between
any client that's connected up so you
saw the diagrams before that we had the
tool service that converted things into
into The Foundry service the command
service then builds one of these
messages depending upon what happened
was something created destroyed glued
did a Model changed or the parent change
and we grind that all up into uh Jason
and send it to the signalr hub whoever's
listening then can decode that message
and make that happen on their server
so that message was not really that
complicated to build here's the message
for move you just
set how it moved and and manage what we
just had to do here was manage a payload
which was nothing more than the glyph or
the object that got moved so that's how
you kept the kept the two things in
sequence
okay
so on the on the subscription side
internally to every uh uh drawing
surface
we are subscribing to Mouse move events
uh the glyph events the creation events
this is where we subscribe on the
command service and then translate it
into Data we can send across the signalr
okay
and then that same command service also
subscribes to signalr HUB captures that
message and then calls the actions
internally
and so
what you get end up getting is this kind
of marble event diagram where a very
simple action might just be
translated immediately sent but a
sequence of like Mouse down Mouse move
Mouse up will be translated into this is
what that means I the shape is now here
right or there might be a thing where
you have a control key and a drag and
that means resize the shape so there's
another there's what you want to do is
have a kind of a second layer language
or we have a second layer of language
that we keep track and and actually
recreate a drawing from all the
sequences that are sent and then the
signal R Hub rather than have you guys
develop it
it's actually built into the system you
can just ask it to be plugged in uh to
uh to the hub
and it will generate that and it will do
all the messaging for you
so with that we're going to uh
we're going to take a look at
collaboration
so like I said before this is this is
the test that I came up with for
collaboration
actually built this animation moving the
two parts because I wanted to know that
that would actually work before I
started debugging the signalr part
so at least now I know if I move two
shapes apart things will stay glued
simultaneously okay
so that was the way I wanted to achieve
the test
and then here's just a little glyph that
I can have first catch messages of
somebody moving a mouse across the
screen
or somebody actually moving
a shape across the screen but with this
now we're going to uh
do the signal heart demo
okay so let me clear this out
and so the first thing you need to do is
you need a partner to work with
so I do that by creating up a new
workspace here
and let me just put these next to each
other
okay now the workspace I put the name of
the workspace
over here on the right side and for some
reason I named them after uh Beatles and
the compass Direction so I didn't get
let me let me do this again because it
looks like
you know it's many times have I done
this for this to be the same guy each
time
not good okay so let's let's try another
another launching here
okay
so we got
Paul okay Paul and Ringo are gonna
play for us today
so
once you once you have the two surfaces
the next step is to start the Hub
okay
so now the central the client hubs are
started on both applications they should
be know about each other and they should
talk to each other
and what happens is this very freaky
effect
of of the mouse moving on the other side
so you know who you're collaborating
with
okay
so with that let's have
let's have
the tug of war start
and at this point you're going to have
to trust me because I only have one
Mouse on one hand right but
I've done this tug of war with friends
across the internet
and it works well but I'm also going to
give you guys
this software is up in the cloud
and if you want to try it yourself
at the party
all you have to do is go to this URL
Vizio canvas
no not that
that's not the right one
okay this this one
I have I have the version up in the URL
you guys can try it yourself
I think it's this one
no that's not that one
ah here it is right
Vizio 2023 Oslo
azurewebsites.net so you can you can do
this with your friends I'm not gonna
you're not gonna hurt anything you're
not going to break anything you can play
together
you don't know who else is going to be
on there there is no authentication
to keep it separate but what's the worst
you can do is just
make some shapes
so anyhow I hope you enjoyed the talk I
enjoy putting it together for you and if
there's any questions I don't know if we
have time for questions but uh I'll
certainly be at the party and uh happy
to talk to you
so thanks so hot
foreign